spider-man far from home is out and as a
diss taping is certified fresh' at 92%
continuing the MC use marvelous rate of
23 consecutive fresh film not a single
rotten 21 of which are certified French
but is it the best spider-man movie of
all time hi everyone I'm Mark Ellis that
is my true identity and welcome to the
after show this is a spoiler heavy show
so if you haven't seen the new
spider-man movie yet I did my best I am
so excited to welcome this panel to the
show first of all we have geek bomb host
Maude Garrett is back gonna be a fun
conversation for sure and joining us is
Rotten Tomatoes certified critic and pop
culture critic the one the only miss
Joelle Monique is here to have you and
we're really gonna talk spider-man
without this next guy Scott movie bans
our returning champion is returning
champion spider-man's meet spider-man
come on we're gonna have a great
conversation about far from home man the
spider-man movies are awesome they just
keep getting an awesome or according to
the tomato meter anyway and so before we
get into our spoiler heavy conversation
about all things spider-man far from
home I do want to throw it to my
panelist individually just to get your
quick take is this a fresh or rotten
movie Joe I'll start with you fresher
rotten absolutely fresh we're getting
our first mainstay villain in a really
long time Tom continues hit it out of
the park it's like very sweet
adorable like cherub baby spider-man and
I love him and on top of that we get
like possibly a new MJ angle which I'm
really excited to explore I am
definitely with you with the MJ angle
Scott man story even have to ask the
question I and you gotta look at it this
way not only did you have spider-man
appearing in Avengers infinity war and
and game and homecoming and into the
spider verse which won the Oscar for
Best Animated Feature but far from home
still feels like a fresh vibrant movie
and that that's a feed onto itself all
right Marv Gary do you agree with here
to cope at fresh fresh fresh fresh it's
just like such a beautiful movie
especially like after the Gravatar that
was endgame you a lot of feels there but
we're kind of like coming out of it and
enjoying these so much Jake Gyllenhaal
tastic he's having the time of his life
I love spider-man and I think that it's
the best it's ever been I cannot believe
that I'm the only person on this show
that is going to say that I think
spider-man far from home is not rotting
I was just teasing y'all of course some
things that I want to get into the first
of which is the villain Mysterio because
I've seen a lot of people raving about
how much they love Jake Gyllenhaal in
this movie that this could be one of the
best MCU villains that they've seen so
that's some heavy company to be in mod
when you look at somebody like a Thanos
or a kill monger a Loki where does
Mysterio rank as far as your favorite
MCU villain you're honestly don't think
it's fair to kind of put him in line
with all those other ones you've got
Thanos you've got you know all of these
villains that have the greater good kind
of aspect where they really do believe
that what their motive is is the better
the betterment of society Jake
Gyllenhaal and Mysterio is a disgruntled
employee
he is just an angry angry guy that feels
like maybe all the money and success and
notoriety shouldn't have gone to someone
like Tony Stark and that he was treated
poorly and his unit like unifying
disgruntled employees around the world
but using technology to prove the point
which is like exactly really what Tony
Stark did using technology to kind of
gain power but he's using it against him
yeah and Scott we've seen this angle
before in the MCU as it relates to Tony
Stark and a former disgruntled employees
so did you just see a lot of shades of
Justin Hammer here was just a little too
Ultron II for you it was just like again
we're mad at Tony Stark and we have to
do form something that gets our revenge
okay well this is not the first time
we've seen a disgruntled employee in a
superhero movie remember amazing
spider-man 2 electro was a disgruntled
employee and remember it wasn't a Batman
forever in which the Joker was at the
Scarlet ex-employer pull out all the
cops book it right but that's the thing
is that it's been done what hasn't been
done is the use of Mysterio now as a
lifelong spider-man fan I love how
they've gone back and made mind the
classic villains like the Green Goblin
Sandman you know electro wasn't so high
but Doc Ock was great but I've always
felt like electro was underappreciated
overlooked as a villain he made his
first appearance an amazing spider-man
number 13 back in 1964 and with today's
special effects in these movies it
like the perfect Playhouse a great
wheelhouse for a character like Mysterio
so to update him as a disgruntled ex
Stark employee I thought was a good
touch and Jake Gyllenhaal he was great
but at first it took me a little while
to warm up to him and here's why smoke
and mirrors baby smoke and mirrors
because you didn't really this is a this
is a good thing about the film you
didn't know in the movie what Mysterio's
motive yes Joe I want you to jump in
there and that real quick because we as
like hardcore comic book fans released
people that follow the news we know that
Jake Gyllenhaal's been cast as this
villainous presence but I think that
people watch this movie my mom might
watch this movie and assume oh this is
Jake puppy dog I chillin home he's gonna
be a good guy teaming up with spider-man
yeah I think that's what really works
about it actually I think we have had a
lot of disgruntled employee kind of
villains but they're so angry and I feel
like he's not as angry at Tony Stark as
he is seeing an opportunity to build him
so I think he's much less disgruntled
and more like I too am a genius and I
haven't had my moment in the spotlight
and now I'm gonna seize it because Tony
Stark is gone I also think it expands
the world in such an interesting way you
now have regular people who are like let
me get in on this superhero action
where's before I would like I kind of
don't want to or I sort I just have to
stop something bad like the world is
gonna end if I if I don't suit up
whereas now we just have guys who are
like I just have like some theatrical
stuff but also you know what's great and
I agree with you I like how they just
sorta they made a current they made the
character fit you know by making a less
of a hero more of a master of technology
but true to the original character of
Mysterio he is the master of illusion
and there is a scene in this movie when
Mysterio really messes with spider-man
driving him bonkers that I swear could
have come right out of a page from
amazing spider-man number 67 Stan Lee
John Romita and it is our it is a great
scene I'm sitting there watching the
movie going like yeah this is exactly
how I envisioned them using Mysterio in
a big MCU man well I'm watching that
scene myself and I'm saying this is such
a worthy opponent to all the powers that
Spiderman has then at the end of the
movie the Spider Man just remember the
add spidey sense and he built himself a
suit and so late you know I my favorite
part of the Mist
reow spider-man was actually the
chemistry that they had together when he
was being that father figure and then
once Mysterio just manifested as a
villain by the end of the movie I just
thought it was it I don't want to use
the word forgettable because you did
bring some things to the MCU but I don't
think that as we get further into these
movies I think we're gonna look at a
first appearance for a villain
like it'd kill monger or a Loki I think
are the two best ones that we've seen
yet and I think that Mysterio might just
be he's not a Malekith but he's just
he's just another another dude and
you're saying that because maybe you
just don't have the knowledge maybe of
the character or that that's some other
people I think that Mysterio is not he's
because he's so different than a lot of
the other villains I don't think he's
gonna get to me like Ultron I'm a
forgettable villain like he doesn't have
like a strong central motivation it
other than destroy I feel like
Mysterio's like desire to be seen
especially as we've just left all the
Avengers being like so that was wild man
and we got to go like we got to go soul
searching and we got to get back to our
roots and we're not here for the
celebrity or even to be you know
spotlighted and lifted up we're just
gonna help like in the background now
sort of kind of where everyone's gone to
I think having villains like Loki who
are like I'm gonna like shower down
giant cloud monsters to destroy the
earth I think it's gonna have to bring
the Avengers back out into the spotlight
and I think if Mysterio is leading the
charge especially knowing how charming
he is knowing how good Marvel is at
revamping and angling like I'll agree
with you that it might have been a
little bit light but I think that's what
the MCU tends to do they're like well
we're not quite sure what people will
like we'll write something very strong
and then what the fans tell us what they
like and we'll Surprise them later and
it's also the MCU is still rebounding
the fans from everything that went on in
endgame and so we just had such a heavy
really two movies with infinity war in
that end game and you put Captain Marvel
in in the middle of that and so it was
nice just to have a movie like Spider
Man far from home that is it has such a
great sense of humor and is so
refreshing in that regard hear hear I
completely agree with you mark because
here is the beauty of far from home so
first of all it works as a standalone
spider-man film
second of all it I think it's a superior
film to 2017 s homecoming okay
and second not many people do it yeah
it's it's a split but I definitely felt
like it was superior in most of the ways
because also what this movie does it is
a coda to Avengers and game it extends
phase three of the MCU just a little bit
further maybe inching towards phase for
just a little bit like for the four
people just wanted a little bit more
after endgame which is a heavy movie a
lot of deep emotional moments here's a
movie that's just super fine it's a
perfect blend of action heart and humor
perfect for the July 4th weekend yeah
before we move on to our name say hero I
just want to get y'all's quick take does
this kill the idea of a multiverse
because we you know it was teased and
that was kind of the fake backstory so
does this mean we're not getting a
multiverse anytime soon in the MCU
doesn't mean that it is actually more
like looking at the structure of typical
Marvel movies we look back at like
Captain America the First Avenger we
know that they like to tease like here's
some Thor stuff it's just pictures just
hanging in the background I think
mentioning it actually means we're going
to get closer to it I think because you
get Peter pontificating of like how
would that work
and he cuz you're like six different
ways that it could possibly work I think
we're gonna get it sooner rather than
later and I think we're gonna come back
later Zhu Li go that's what they were
teasing it and that's where they were
teasing god your body language says I've
said the word means that it exists I've
tried to get out of Amy Pascal with into
the spider-verse the fact that the
multiverse is definitely in existence
and I was like is this canon and are we
leading into that and will we see that
split multiverse in an upcoming
spider-man movie to which she was
incredibly Punk but you know with this
is a second time we've really seen or
heard about it even though it was smoke
and mirrors I mean hello that's that
mysterio that's it yeah I liked it a
little bit just as if nothing else as a
nod to what we got with the you know
into the multiverse movie but I think
that we could be seeing more of the
multiverse coming up in the MC I would
also love to see a live-action Miles
Morales movie currently and we should be
very happy with and that would be Tom
Holland and in this movie the way that
Tom Holland kind of tries to take the
mantle
Tony Stark I feel like Tony Stark is
always gonna be a presence in these
movies going forward even though it's
just gonna be the spirit of Tony Stark
living breathing through spider-man is
he the successor to Tony Stark in your
eyes okay well first of all I agree that
that the in this film definitely feels
not just like Tony Stark as a presence
it feels like he's in the movie and he
kind of is in one particular scene this
movie is a love letter to Tony Stark and
it is a great passing of the torch a
passing of the baton from Tony Stark who
saw Peter Parker as a great not just a
protege but like next in line to really
take charge of the Avengers and he's
only like it said Marty 16 years old
there's a whole lot of places for this
to go but I think with this film
again again it's a coda to endgame where
we saw against boy or art this is a big
one we saw Iron Man he's gone he's out
so this furthest sort of feels like a
further coda to him and a tribute to his
character but I think after this you're
gonna see and feel the presence of Tony
Stark much much further in the rearview
mirror it felt like the end of endgame
for a while there Joelle but then once
we get Spidey on the jet and he's
hanging out with happiness on his own
suit it's like this is the new Tony
Stark do you look at spider-man as the
new face of the MCU should he be the new
face of the MCU
and he's capable of doing it I think
people love Tom Holland they're having
really great reactions to him I think
what I've really loved about the MCU is
that it's sort of all in company
encompassing but it also has like it's
dealing with a lot of adult themes and
stuff spider-man's still very young to
me I think Tony leaving weapons of mass
destruction to a 16 year old is
questionable parenting boy that being
said so so I'll say this I'm not sure
how I feel about spider-man being the
center of the Marvel Universe he's your
friendly neighborhood spider-man I'm how
is he gonna lead the Avengers and house
though we're gonna take orders from
spider-man and it's just it's a lot of
like weirdness on that level however if
we're talking about a spiritual like
inheritance of the role Tony gave which
is sort of the heart of the MCU that guy
people turn to when they're not quite
sure how they're feeling about something
I think his decision to step back he
took the exact same route Tony took
after infinity war
like I just want to be my family I'm not
putting on this suit I'm gonna just step
away I'll monitor things I'm gonna check
in but like please don't involve me I
think that he was trying to achieve what
Tony achieved while he was gone
and I think that makes him the spiritual
inheritor of Tony's legacy and if Tony
Stark was the spiritual leader of the
MCU I would still argue that Captain
America was the face of the Avengers and
we had a Captain America cameo in this
Anthony Mackey's taking over for Captain
America but that got cut at the end
because I didn't want to undercut what
was already happening in the third scene
so I would have loved to have seen that
cameo so maybe hope for the blu-ray do
you think that spider-man is the logical
choice to be the face of the MCU or do
you have another candidate mod um I want
to step out from sort of like the law of
it all and hi Mike the hypothetical and
I want to talk about the Hollywood
budgets and you know that side of things
I think that you've got Tom Holland who
was brought on board as a no-name and
that he is now all encompassing as a spy
a Marvel superhero I think that they can
afford him I think that they've signed
him onto a 10-year deal he himself has
said that he'll play spider-man for the
rest of his life I think that Tom
Holland is the new Hugh Jackman whereas
we are going to see this guy play
spider-man for the next 16 years like I
think that the tenure is gonna be very
long and established and that's gonna be
great you ever gonna replace Tony Stark
no we need the juxtaposition between the
ingrained heroes that have the life
experience that you know you know that
the end of the world is constantly on
their mind and then bringing it back to
what is human like what's so human and
like what's innocent which is spider-man
just wanting to kiss a girl that he
likes that's a thing that's a thing
spider-man still has a lot of growing up
to do he's only 16 years old we haven't
seen me get the job yet at the Daily
Bugle working for JPL it's done that's
not gonna happen
he's not gonna get a job as a
photographer already the first thing
that happened in that post-credit scene
when Jake um when Jay John Jameson is
like Peter Parker better duck which was
by the way it was awesome I really don't
have to work it all as a host because
that incredible post-credit scene where
you do have and it was a good
post-credit scene anyway because it did
give Mysterio kind of a life after
supposed death and we're like oh god he
revealed I can't believe it and then at
least the theater that Joelle and I were
in
exploded when J Duncan great played by
JK Simmons back on the screen I it our
theater was making so much noise and
rightfully so I couldn't really
understand where he was going with it
for a while then I picked up that he is
anti spider-man and he's just very kind
of blogger II like I'm gonna attack
spider-man with this grain of salt of
possible truth that I have so I like
where that was going just as a somebody
wants to be entertained in the moment
but now as we step back and look at what
this actually does for the MCU we know
who spider-man is now that gonna change
what isn't gonna change everything
changes especially because here's what
I'll be most interested to see it's we
know Peter does not want anybody he's
around to be hurt and he says
consistently throughout the movie you
know if my identity is revealed I'm not
gonna be doing this so do we come back
in Peter's like nah man I'm just Peter
now but also like spider-man has such a
strong relationship with New York and
it's one of my favorite things about
homecoming which is still my favorite
spider-man movie of all time
it was this idea of how connected he is
how does New York let Peter Parker just
go by now like you are spider-man so
it'll be interesting to see and maybe
that's the way they force him to get
into the Avengers if he skips the bugle
if he you know instead of going to
college he's got a ton of great
professors already around him in the
Avengers maybe they're training him up
teaching him and he's I don't know
learning how to run Tony Stark's
corporation but but you're you're he's
still a kid he needs to have the
experience of college to grow as a
person you know yeah sure he's around
the best people you know who could
really mentor him in the Avengers but he
said he needs to grow as a person and
have the experience kids right now who
are spider-man's age many of them are
not going to college they just can't
afford it and so maybe they lean more
into the coin generation of how they're
more they make hundreds million dollars
going right to the NBA and LeBron James
has done a pretty good job I would say
what Brian James is the best super here
we have on earth right now he is our
current spider-man and if you look at
where Peter Parker's going Scott I think
that honestly the best use for him right
now because I do agree with what you
said is that he is a kid and he's not
ready to handle the responsibility that
I think a you know that Anthony Maggie's
now Captain America could or what to
chala what about a child that Wahb think
but here's the thing with spider-man
because we know who Peter Parker is I
think he is a great distraction I think
that he is something you can dangle in
front of villains they all go after him
and we have all these other Avengers
that can just come out of the woodwork
and that's how you take down a threat no
matter what no matter what he grows into
whether he goes to to the work for the
Daily Bugle whether it goes whether he
goes to Empire State University whether
he meets Gwen Stacy whether he starts
dating Betty Brent who they introduced
in far from home how dare you he's not
gonna date his best friend's ex well I
mean Betty Brent and there are basic
rules whose husband was the hot goblin
but I'm totally going off the rails here
but the other thing is you know as much
as I love far from home the problem I
have with the film and this is a problem
is that while it's really cool to see
spider-man finally interact in pal
around with Iron Man and Captain America
and the rest of the Avengers in the MCU
there's something to be said about just
having a movie that's just about
spider-man I just want a movie about
spider-man
which is why in terms of live-action
movie spider-man 2 from 2004 where Tobey
Maguire directed by Sam Raimi to me is
still the best spider-man movie of them
all it's just because we've already had
that it's already been done and I think
that that's that was a really poignant
moment that I had during the end credits
scene where it was like we know
spider-man's story so well because this
is the third iteration that we've seen
and I was ready I was bracing myself for
when he does become a photographer for
the Daily Bugle because it's like that's
the story that I know and I'm ready for
it so to hear that that's off the table
now we are now venturing into mysterious
grounds hahaha this is like you know
unfamiliar territory so I'm sad that
we're not gonna see Tom Hollands version
of what that looks like what keeps this
movie from being like the best
live-action movie for me though is that
it's such a busy film there's so much
going on there going all over Europe you
have all these supporting characters in
Peter Parker's life you have all these
other characters in the MCU like happy
Hogan and you know Nick Fury and there's
so much story going on too that I felt
like at times that Spiderman was a guest
star in his own movie and as a
spider-man fan I
just want a movie about spider-man
before I give you a movie about
spider-man and possibly the next
stand-alones stanlon spider-man movie we
get but that has been a minute as well
because they could have Tom Hardy venom
if you're gonna put JK Simmons back is
Jay jonah Jameson anything's possible no
so Joel do you think that we could see
Tom Hardy's venom go up against Tom
Hollands Spidey
sorry fans this iteration of venom your
points and love are totally valid and I
respect them Oh Lord I don't like that
version of venom I don't understand it I
think we were talking a little bit
before the show about how sort of
expansive that character is based off of
how the venom movie ended so maybe morph
into something else I'll sit Marvel
could do it I hope they don't
I think they will do it and I think that
listen I I did not like the standalone
venom movie but I did like not love but
I did think that spider-man 3 from 2007
not the best spider-man movie but not
the worst either it has its moments oh
come on
you know the dark Peter Parker listen
that was a bit much right but Eddie
Brock is played by yeah Topher nice I
thought that he was actually really good
but I think obviously there's a lot of
potential for a really great venom
villain against spider-man that's coming
ever all the fans definitely want to see
it they need to get that right and I
think that's coming soon enough presence
to go up against Spidey or do you just
want to see him I wanna see some honey
and I want to see them come together I
like Tom who's being used as a verb a
gerund everything else it's it's time to
move on to the next post-credit scene
which was another twist that we got that
really blew the MCU wide open because we
thought we were watching Nicki Maria we
we weren't we were watching Scrolls play
the role in the Nick Fury is off to
another
stuff in more of a Captain Marvel sort
of setting so he was having a fake
holiday then he gets off the screen then
he says back to work so do you like that
twist that it was actually Nick Fury the
entire time in far from home Maude
Garrett all right so here's a little
thing that I'm noticing with Marvel
we're starting to fall into crutches and
these two things that we've established
in the Marvel Universe now can kind of
solve any problem and that is the
introduction of Scrolls being
shapeshifters and potentially playing
anyone which is good good and bad
because the good thing is I now want to
watch this movie again and find these
quite now obvious hints that it wasn't
them necessarily like they had met
before Nick Fury and spider-man and he
said nice to meet you and I was like
that's a little weird maybe I can't
remember so it's like I like those
little payoffs but at the same time it's
like someone's gonna die and then they
turn into a scroll and you're like oh
cool the other one is time travel you
know so we've seen that that's a that's
an easy fix and if you don't like it go
back in time and do it again so I think
that these are - sort of like very
blanket very clever but very forgiving
kind of crutches that they can lean it
yes I had the pleasure of seeing this
movie last week and so I said yeah like
I'm gonna give myself the weekend and
then I'll know how I feel about this
post-credit scene but I have no idea how
they feel telling me how ok well well
first of all I hate to say this but the
the better credit scene was the big
reveal to the city of New York and to
the world that Peter Parker was
spider-man what came after that was the
reveal of dick furious as a scroll uh I
didn't really care that much about it
because I did not care for the movie
Captain Marvel I thought it was bland I
thought it was weak and I just really
didn't think that the character really
said well sorry I'm gonna get a lot of
heat for this but I thought the Captain
Marvel was the weakest movie in the MCU
you should never get peace world a dark
world is also not good and neither as
Iron Man 2 and neither according to the
galaxy okay so so defend this
post-credit scene first your well
becomes white why is this so important
it Oh Nick Fury is off doing what Nick
is our link across the MCU he is the
thing that brings us all
together so I was personally shopping
people who were like but I knew
instantly something was wrong with Nick
Fury like Mysterio's antics not bad
great like after the bar scene
there's no reason Nick Fury who's a
thousand times smarter than me isn't
picking up on these things something is
wrong and the whole time I'm freaked out
like what are they doing to Nick Fury
like he came back and he's disoriented
and he doesn't have contacts and
spider-man's the only one he can reach
out to there are still so many people on
the planet Earth this is a setup or
something weird is happening I don't
understand it then we get to the end and
there's just like great reveal of like
Nick is offworld he is setting up the
scrolls to build or sustain something on
earth we don't know what it is what is
your mission in outer space what are you
doing out there do you need more heroes
are you concerned are you secret walls
just one man so this is why we show do
these shows because we have our opinions
they can be changed during the course of
a conversation gosh oh my gosh well
there you go Wow
whether you're watching at home or
you're hosting the show and you're not
sure what Secret Wars is I got you just
give me a quick run-through from each
panelist back in the early 80s 1984 to
be exact the Marvel Universe was shaken
up when all the greatest heroes like
spider-man Fantastic Four The Hulk and
the greatest villains like Doctor Doom
and so on were taken to another world by
a great being called the Beyonder who
made them fight each other and whoever
won would have the powers of the
Beyonder and be able to control the
universe it is actually a story that in
terms of the movies could be bigger into
stakes than even Avengers infinity war
and endgame and I like the concept of
that's actually where face 4 could go
so basically spider-man we know you used
to love being with your friendly
neighborhood spider-man in saving delis
it's gonna get a little bigger than that
what we're topping to get to and that
would be your overarching thought about
how we ended phase 3 because this is the
official end of phase 3 and now as we
get into phase 4 and where does this
rank in your favorite spider-man films
of all time so Joe let's start with you
fitting into phase 3
right movie to launch phase four I think
if we had had that Captain America scene
I would feel better about this being the
start for to me this was such a like an
addendum I don't I don't like it I don't
I don't like to me I don't need a post
credit scene movie you know what I mean
like I'm just
we had a definitive ending and it was so
good and I came into this part knee
where are we going before what game
exactly that's the end of it so we were
like it's like an extension of three
well who needs that like why are we here
I feel like only what I was really
hoping for was like what's the new
direction is it Avengers or Avengers
like we don't have Tony anymore when you
start going in a new direction is it
gonna be the teasing of x-men like and
it turns out it's the teasing possibly
of Secret Wars but it it to me did it
doesn't it didn't connect to anything I
feel I still feel out in space I don't
know what's happening in phase four I
didn't really need it and it's the Exile
after being punched in the gut so it's
like whoo all right we're back I need I
don't feel like it's a full stop it's
not like the end it's not like it's
almost like the webbing pun intended
between the two so it's like like the
year the inhale like that you get to get
back into the next one I don't see it as
a start and you know like a it's not
black and white like I think it's
something we'll be able to measure
better five or six films out when we can
understand again the great thing about
the MCU is that it is developing
Universal storytelling it is been my
obsession since I was a child I love
crossover I love like extending the
universes it's why I like the fact that
we have like eight thousand stories in
here because if you're an MCU diehard
and you've seen all these movies and
you've watched them again these doors
are super easy to follow because you're
like oh hey Happy's here that's really
cool I think that the rewatch ability of
this movie is gonna be so high there's
so much to go back and be like oh I see
that there and like I see how this
connects to our future stuff so I'm
looking forward to you know our next
thing movies coming out and they're
coming back to revisit this it's got
this rewatch ability for you make a
great film - so does that elevate far
from home above homecoming is that why
you have that ranking we watch ability
makes a movie I mean I've I've seen into
the spider-verse like four times now and
there's so much to into the spider-verse
especially Easter eggs for MCU fan
and spider-man fans to find so many
things and also the depth of that film
which I saw as the it's a wonderful life
of spider-man movies which we could talk
about on another after show for into the
spider person which we can do like
anyway but I saw far from home like what
like I said at the top of the show as a
coda as an epilogue to ain't game what
you just said marred about it being sort
of like you know catching your breath
after being punched in the gut in game
was a very heavy movie a lot of
emotional moments and it ended it ended
phase three in a really emotional
satisfying away you know 22 movies or
loving years but you know this is sort
of like peaking ahead of what what
happens after that I'd like to just know
what happens after that
and it doesn't really advance at the
phase four in any definitive way except
for I guess that post-credit scene that
I hold like a whole lot more than out
now than I did 10 minutes ago but I
think it's it's gonna be a rewatchable
film and I get on first viewing I
thought it was a very busy movie but you
know maybe I'll like it better when I
watch it again and again
oh here we go so we don't get Peter
Parker working for the Daily Bugle
because he's no longer an anonymous but
guess who is no malice as a graphic
designer
or the like oh my gosh and works so well
came harder the hole is with their
addiction and then you topped it with
Miles Morales so this is what we're
doing right now as fans of the MCU is
that we're looking into phase forward
saying well this is what we most want to
see one of things I would love to see in
more spider-man movies is more of Mary
Jane I want to see more zendaya because
I thought she was so good in this boot I
think it was a giant lead getting to
know her character a bit more we had a
little bit more of that secrecy you know
I like that secret society that they
both have together and she's holding the
biggest secret on her show she knows she
definitely feel like they did more with
her and had to cut out because she has
like maybe two really good character
pivots in the movie that we don't get
any kind of like lead into she sort of
just like and I'm a spy and I was like
ding it could we have had like little
teases of this earlier she
great in the role I think we had we had
so much work to do setting up phase four
though so if I give you a one event that
needs to happen in phase four is it
secret worth is it x-men it's got to let
you go first
what's the one thing we want to see in
phase well I think the thing and listen
as much as I'm a die-hard fan of secret
secret Boris I mean I was like 15 when
that came out in 1984 yeah I know but I
think the thing that fans most want to
see now that Disney bought Fox is x-men
and Fantastic Four in the MCU and a
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios said that was still a few years
away but that's what fans really do want
to see and and that's going to happen
and they're gonna reboot and recast the
characters just like they did with Tom
Hollands spider-man so there's a vote
for x-men and Joelle I'm also going to
give my vote to x-men storm is coming I
don't know why I don't know where I know
about four actresses are competing for
the role already just sight unseen like
we would just like it when it's
available I'm secretly rooting for you
TV but yeah it's not so secretly utd
Barak a she's amazing I also think that
you have Scarlet Witch and this
opportunity to make her the beginning
and center of the x-men again it's just
like about the MCU so much is that they
do that great surprising of us like
they're just like you don't know what's
gonna happen you think you do we're
gonna give you things that you like but
we're gonna just mutate them so that
they're new and interesting and fun and
I feel like with the x-men it's just
there's so much potential and the fact
that we get so many great wars between
the x-men and the Avengers and that
could be coming up and we're drawing new
sides and then but what I really want to
see is more fleshing out of these young
characters to be honest Kamala Khan
should be there and be amazing we should
have America Chavez needs to come in and
just kick so much but I'd love to see
silk there's just so many great young
characters and I think we could build
like a great like little high school
kind of Young Avengers world I think
it's what's been sorely missing from
superhero movies for a long time and I'm
desi needs to do Teen Titans already
there's that can of warm so Garrett what
do we what's the one thing we need to
see in alright so I'm a little bit
overwhelmed with introducing all the
x-men and it's like how are you gonna do
that when we have so much happening
already and
don't want it to get convoluted so here
we go hold your head cuz your minds
gonna blow we are introducing the
multiverse and in another universe
they're not super heroes and super
villains they're just called x-men and
that's how we get the x-men and that's
how they are involved so they're not so
it's just a multiverse with a whole new
set of Heroes that are just yeah they're
not two separate stories on two separate
storylines and then they combine and
themselves well not I think that they
would necessarily exist it's a
multiverse but instead of having you
know your Avengers you have your x-men I
don't feel like I'm in a dorm room with
Donald Sutherland and I'm saying so
you're saying one tiny atom in my
universe our minds are blown and that's
all the time that we have today on the
after show I want to thank my panelists
for not only an incredible spoiler heavy
review of spider-man far from home but
also giving us so much to feast on her
phase four and beyond of the MCU and now
it's your turn comment in the chat
section right now here on YouTube I know
you're already probably doing it let us
know your take on everything that you
saw us debate today what did you love
about far from home what did you want to
see do better it Mysterio live up to the
height where do you want to see face or
in the MCU go from here we love hearing
from y'all so hit that Bell if you're
watching us on YouTube right now that's
gonna give you an alert anytime we have
a new after so drop and of course
subscribe right here to the Rotten
Tomatoes YouTube channel for my expert
panelists I and merely Mark Ellis I know
I'm not a scroll have a good one we'll
see you next time
[Music]